in this video i want to talk about
competitive inhibitors and
non-competitive inhibitors of enzymes
and how they affect the line weaver
burke plot so let's begin by talking
about it about the definitions of both
competitive and non-competitive
inhibitors
individually and sort of what they do
so
inhibitors obviously they're going to
inhibit the function of the enzyme how
so if you think about competitive
inhibitors you think of the word compete
right so
competitive inhibitors they compete with
the substrate
for binding at the active site okay so
competitive inhibitors they bind
at
the active site
of an enzyme
okay so in that sense they're sort of um
competing right
with the substrate
right and i'm going to abbreviate um
substrate as s and i'm going to
abbreviate inhibitors as i
so
they're competing for the substrate so
they're both trying to bind at the
active site um competitive inhibitors
and the substrate so whereas
non-competitive inhibitors are a little
bit different they
bind at a site other than the active
site
okay
okay so
with competitive inhibitors if the
substrate binds to the active site then
the inhibitor can't but if the inhibitor
binds at the active site then the
substrate can't so essentially what's
going on here is that you can't have
um
essentially actually let me write this
down so i the inhibitor
blocks
the substrate s
from binding
okay so if the substrate can't bind the
enzyme is inhibited from doing its
function which is to turn that substrate
into a product
okay
so now
the i blocks the s from from binding so
this means then that that you can't have
have
the substrate
and
the inhibitor
bind
at the same time
okay
so if this is the case if i is blocking
the substrate from binding and you can't
have the substrate and the inhibitor
bind at the same time because they both
find the same site essentially what you
have
is you have
um you have reduced
these competitive inhibitors reduce
the enzymes
affinity for their substrate
right because
you can't have the substrate and the
inhibitor bind at the same time so once
the the enzyme binds an inhibitor it
can't bind the substrate so it has once
it binds the inhibitor it has a reduced
infinity for its substrate now
we've talked about a particular measure
of affinity earlier and that was km
so if we have reduced the enzymes
affinity for the substrate what did we
do to the km
if you recall we've increased
the km
this means that the km increases because
a high km means a low affinity and a low
km means a high affinity so up here we
reduce the end times infinity for the
substrate
and the km must have increased
okay so
that means when we plot the lineweaver
perk plot which intercepts should we
expect to to change well the x-intercept
the x-intercept will change
okay so i'm going to note that here
okay so if the km increases that means
the x-intercept
should change
okay the x-intercept changed
what about v max what happens to v max
in the case of a competitive inhibitor
the v max does not change
and the reason why
is quite simply because
you can still basically since since it's
basically a war of numbers and what i
mean by that is that the substrate and
the inhibitor are both trying to get to
that active site whichever one there's
more of is probably going to be the
thing that's likely to bind the enzyme
so
if you add the inhibitor and you mean
you're going to reduce the vmax to a
certain extent but you can overcome that
by adding by adding substrate right and
eventually if you add a high enough
substrate concentration you can still
reach that vmax because then then it's
basically a war of numbers if there's
let's say um 10 enzymes and you add 10
inhibitors and you only have five
substrates well the inhibitors are going
to sort of take over but if you add a
thousand or a million substrates then
they're going to overpower the effect of
the inhibitor so the v max will not
change because
because
you can add
because adding substrate or adding more
substrate
can overcome the effect
of the competitive inhibitor
i'm going to abbreviate competitive
inhibitor just like this
comp inhib
okay so the v max does not change which
means that the y-intercept stays the
same
okay so that's what we should expect for
competitive inhibitors and just to give
you a quick little visual i suppose if
you imagine a
an enzyme looking like this
right
and it has a substrate that's circular
and you you have an inhibitor
that is
also around the same size right at least
circular they can both fit in this
active site right so whichever one binds
is going to stop the other one from
binding
okay
for non-competitive inhibitors we've
just noted here that that
earlier that they're a little bit
different they bind at a site other than
the active site okay so
the way they inhibit
enzymes is they inhibit
the enzyme by changing its conformation
uh confirmation
which is sort of just like the overall
structure right we talked earlier about
hemoglobin and myoglobin and how they
have or should be hemoglobin in
particular actually we talked about how
it has an r state and a t state those
are two different conformations when you
change the confirmation of a particular
protein you can alter its function
so
what what happens with non-competitive
inhibitors is they're a little bit
different so
what happens is that
when um
with the inhibitor binds at a site other
than the active site so essentially what
can happen is that you can have the
enzyme
bound to the substrate and to the
inhibitor okay so what so um
enzyme
can have
both
the
substrate
and
the inhibitor
bound
at the same time why is that well
because they're binding at different
sites right
so if the active site is taken up by the
by the substrate then a site somewhere
else is where the inhibitor is going to
bind so what and what
but they sort of uh represent that by
they kind of mention that as
the esi
right the enzyme substrate inhibitor
complex can form
right that
this cannot the esi complex cannot form
with competitive inhibitors but with
non-competitive inhibitors it can
okay so what happens here
this enzyme substrate inhibitor complex
once it's formed it is it you know it
makes the enzyme less effective how does
it actually do that
um
actually before i mention that
before i go into that particular detail
if the enzyme substrate and inhibitor
can all bind at the same time then
there's no reduced affinity right
there's no reduced affinity
for for the substrate okay so there's no
reduced
affinity
for the substrate right which means what
happened to the km it should have stayed
the same
right which means
uh that we shouldn't see a difference in
our x-intercept right the x-intercept
should be the same
but now this enzyme substrate inhibitor
complex right is not effective
okay
complex that complex cannot
make product
so what ends up happening is
this this enzyme is reduced in its
effectiveness specifically its v max is
lowered
okay
so the v max decreases
okay
which means that we should expect to see
a
a difference in our y-intercept the
y-intercept changed
okay
so um
note here though that there you cannot
cannot overcome
the effect
of a non-competitive inhibitor
by adding
more substrate and the reason why is
because
the enzyme substrate complex the enzyme
substrate inhibitor complex can still
form
okay
so let's kind of see how this all plays
into the line we have work plot actually
in just a moment um here if we have a
non-competitive inhibitor and we have an
enzyme that looks like this
um for instance
okay let's say this is the active site
here okay
and this is another site okay
so
we can imagine the substrate the
substrate being you know circular and
able to fit here
right and then we can imagine the
inhibitor
the inhibitor being
um
you know something that could fit there
so if we if this all happens to to
to to you know form we can get this sort
of um
this sort of confirmation here in which
we have the inhibitor bound
right
and the substrate bound
right and this here now
is the
um
the enzyme substrate inhibitor complex
right which is
rendered pretty much useless okay
so how do these affect the linewaver
plot okay
so if we have
a line over brick plot with no inhibitor
this is what we got here okay we have a
particular y-intercept a particular
x-intercept right so in the case of a
competitive inhibitor as we just
mentioned just a moment ago right
we have a change in km so as the km
increases the x-intercept changed right
but but the v-max did not so we'll still
have the same y-intercept so with a
competitive inhibitor with a competitive
inhibitor the km increased okay so the
x-intercept changed now where did the
x-intercept move they moved to the left
to the right well let's think about this
if the km
increased right what does that mean that
means the x-intercept right is equal to
since it's equal to negative one over
the km the km is now a bigger number
then one divided by a bigger number is
going to yield a smaller x-intercept
right so for a competitive inhibitor
let's do this in green so for a
competitive inhibitor
right we should expect since the km is
bigger the x-intercept
will be smaller right in magnitude
right so what's smaller in magnitude is
shift to the left or a shift to the
right well if this here this number is
zero right
as you move away from zero you're
increasing in magnitude so if the
x-intercept is now smaller in magnitude
we would expect to shift to the right
okay so the x-intercept shifts to the
right so for a competitive inhibitor you
would still expect it to
intersect at the y-intercept here
right the same y-intercept but now
since it's km changed we have a new
x-intercept so this is how the graph
would look with a competitive
inhibitor inhibitor
right the x-intercept shifts to the
right because a larger km makes a
smaller x-intercept okay so then how
would that that
how would a non-competitive
inhibitor uh how would its graph change
well it would have the same x-intercept
right as we mentioned earlier have the
same x-intercept because the km stays
the same but the v-max decreased so so
the
y-intercept changed okay so let's do
this in purple so
for for a non-competitive inhibitor
for a non-competitive inhibitor
what should happen well
v max decreased right so v max involves
the y intercept so if we have the v max
right the v max was smaller so one
divided by a smaller v max will yield a
larger y-intercept so the y-intercept
will be larger in magnitude
right
so
here if we're dividing by a smaller v
max then the y-intercept will be a
bigger number well what's bigger shift
up or down
well the bigger numbers are are upwards
right so
the for a non-competitive inhibitor we'd
still have that same
that same x value but we'd have a larger
y-intercept so it looks something like
this
okay so this purple graph is with a
non-competitive
inhibitor
okay so a non-competitive inhibitor
would shift the y-intercept upwards okay
so this is a new y-intercept
right and the same x-intercept and then
for for the competitive inhibitor we
have a new x-intercept
okay so i hope that all makes sense and
i hope that was very helpful um i'll now
provide you in the next video i'll
provide you with an example of the
language plot and i hope that will be
helpful as well see you next time